for a streamer there's no sweeter shock
to the system
than having someone from your community
donate you a fat stack of cash
somebody that for whatever reason loves
what you do and has money to blow
so they send you multiple hundred and
sometimes thousand dollar donations
all of a sudden it's like you're living
the twitch dream
but there's also a dark side to twitch
donations that can be just as big a
shock
one that can leave you in debt with
nowhere else to turn
i'm talking about chargebacks
[Music]
all right guys this story i'm about to
tell you is absolutely insane but before
we get to that i have to tell you to
subscribe to the channel
not only does it help us understand what
stories you want to see
it helps us chase those stories down so
please do me a favor subscribe to the
channel
and if you're going to leave a comment
about what record i have on the shelf
how my hair looks or how i'm using my
hands honestly
i don't give a [ __ ] imagine somebody
donating you 10 grand
for no other reason than they just like
your content
that [ __ ] is life-changing i'm done i'm
not gonna
no that's not what you're supposed to do
with money
why ten thousand dollars
over the years we've seen sporadic
instances of wealthy donators dropping
huge amounts of cash on unsuspecting
streamers
hell we even covered one of those
stories with a guy named fatty mellon
i get there i do like 10-minute cardio
i'm here to talk to you about when
donations go wrong when streamers end up
on the hook for hundreds and sometimes
thousands of dollars
now i started looking into chargebacks
after reading this insane twitter thread
from a valorem streamer named average
jonas who ended up owing
5400 because of this weird
refund system it's an absolutely wild
story
involving a fake heart surgeon and over
20
different donations but before i walk
you through his and a few other horror
stories i've come across
let me just quickly explain what the
hell a chargeback actually is
in the context of twitch a chargeback is
when somebody who donated a streamer any
amount of money
decides to charge back that donation and
basically
refund their cash obviously chargebacks
exist for a reason
maybe you got drunk one night and
donated way more than you
intended to or maybe your kid took your
credit card and blew twenty thousand
dollars on their favorite streamers
my point is humans make mistakes and
there's plenty of legitimate reasons as
to why you'd want to refund your money
now if a chargeback is approved and the
key word here being approved
if a chargeback is approved by paypal or
any other third-party system that a
streamer uses to accept donations
then the money is refunded and the
streamer can potentially be hit with an
extra charge
of up to 20 dollars per chargeback but
here's the thing
the chargeback system on twitch is
extremely easy to exploit
in a worst case scenario somebody can
donate large amounts of money to you
multiple times in one stream
and then charge back all of that money
later on now you might be wondering
why the hell anybody would want to run a
chargeback scam like this
well honestly in the situations that i'm
talking about here
it was all for clout and a good troll
and this is exactly what happened to the
streamer average jonas who i mentioned
earlier
the first thing was that this guy came
into my stream and
he started giving me like 100 and 200
donations so never more than two or
three hundred
in separate donations and each time it
was like it felt really casual for him
like
it's just like oh let's celebrate this
guy you know this was like a positive
message or something he was pretending
to be
a heart 27 year old heart surgeon
just wanting to make the world a better
place and like it's just insane
now seemingly wealthy people making
large donations on twitch is becoming
more and more common
because on top of making a streamer's
day and putting some good out into
the world you're also kind of chasing
that sweet sweet clout
your name sits atop a streamer's
donation leaderboard you get a vip
tag the community knows who you are the
spotlight is now
on you and with how popular some twitch
streamers are these days
that's a pretty big spotlight just ask
mr beast and ninja
mr beast donates 1000 says no healing
okay so we are already moving on to the
no gun no go
no which gun all right you didn't you
didn't say you didn't specialize which
gotta get the drop so i'll just drop
i'll start my gray pistol thanks beast
and this idea of chasing clout is
exactly what average jonas thinks that
his fake heart surgeon donator was doing
and then the chargeback started
basically this
person wanted of course exposure because
like my community grows a lot
you have like 70 000 people stopping by
for a day so he gets a lot of attention
for being this
giving person and you know he gets the
vip tag
and then over time of course i start to
get more and more
worried i'd say because like the first
donation
suddenly got a refund request so the
first donation gets a chargeback request
and obviously jonas is confused so he
goes to the donator to ask what the deal
is
and the donator says hey that's weird
that wasn't me
basically saying i paid you that money
in good faith there shouldn't be a
problem
and this kept happening the donator kept
telling stories of being a heart surgeon
whose parents died in front of him
making these donations charging them
back later on
and then stringing jonas along saying
that it wasn't him
he doesn't know what the problem is in
total this person donated over 20 times
for a total amount of 5 400
but jonas eventually realized that this
was probably a scam
so he confronted the person so basically
he just kept on building a larger and
larger scam
so after a while when i started to
realize this was probably a person who's
like
just lying straight to my face i
straight up just asked him for
id somehow to like identify that you're
a real human being and that you're
telling the truth because he was just
talking about
being a heart surgeon in this hospital
and having a lot of
money that he doesn't need and all that
stuff you know and as soon as
i asked him to reveal his identity he
just disappeared he deleted his account
on discord he deleted his
twitch account but luckily i saved
all the evidence first because this was
more than 20 donations
yeah once they knew the jig was up they
just pieced the [ __ ] out
and the worst part is the thing that
broke this story wide open for me
is the fact that jonas is not the first
streamer this person has pulled this
scam
on before this exact same fake heart
surgeon thing
they've done it to multiple other people
according to jonas
after he tweeted out about having to pay
back this 5400
and that he was being scammed 10 other
people reached out to him and said the
exact same thing happened to them
it was basically just scamming people
left and right and i also have received
messages from
more than 10 other streamers being
scanned by the same person
now i haven't been able to confirm all
10 stories
but one person did get back to me and
they said yes the same username scammed
them
and then i found a streamer who has a
tweet pinned basically saying that the
same username that scammed jonas
also scammed them for five thousand one
hundred dollars
okay but how and why are these streamers
left to pay back these insane amounts of
money
it's because again depending on the
third party system you use to accept
donations
there could be a window of 120 days to
file a chargeback request
so as a streamer if you decide to spend
that donation money
and then somebody decides to be an
[ __ ] and file a chargeback request on
the 100th and 19th day of that window
you now have to cough up all of that
money you just spent
and that's why at this point now i don't
really use that money
unless it's for like smaller things and
i make sure that there's like a buffer
of ten thousand dollars there
like you should never have less than the
highest donation you've received
and remember on top of having to pay
back that donation amount
you now have to pay all of the fees from
paypal
or whatever the hell service that you're
using and those can be up to
twenty dollars a pop so even if you were
smart about it and held on to that
donation money just in case you did have
to pay it back in a situation like this
you would still be on the hook for all
of those paypal transaction fees
and in the case of jonas that means an
extra 400 dollars you have to pay out
now thankfully jonas's story has a happy
ending because
after his initial tweet gained some
traction ninja stepped in
and actually paid off that 5400 charge
but unfortunately situations like
jonas's are all too common
hell looking at the replies to his
original tweet i found
three different anecdotal stories about
streamers dealing with chargeback
situations in the thousands of dollars
take twitch streamer jordy as another
example
back in april he got hit with a
chargeback scam that left him on the
hook for five thousand one hundred
dollars
now with no way to pay back that money
jordy's community
thankfully saved the day clarity with
the 143.12
my [ __ ] man it's pretty screwed up
that a donation scam can happen so
easily like this and one of the only
solutions at your disposal as a streamer
is to have your community donate their
way
out of your debt and at this point you
might be wondering well
isn't there something streamers can do
to fight back against this
and yeah there is kind of remember how i
stressed the approval
aspect of a chargeback request well
that's because you can dispute a
chargeback as a streamer
if you provide evidence that the
donation that was given to you
was actually intended to be given to you
or if you're lucky
you have evidence that these 20
different donations
were actually a scam this is why you see
a lot of streamers write in their bios
no refunds when it comes to donations
the basic thinking being that
if you're upfront about it you're making
it very clear that
mistake or not if you donate to me
that's
it also streaming services like stream
labs provide a sort of chargeback
protection
where they'll dispute any chargebacks
with paypal or any third-party system
on your behalf but there's problems with
this evidence-based approach as well
to continue using paypal as an example
they often side with the consumer
and in a way that makes sense because in
a perfect world
if somebody has their credit card stolen
you want to believe them
so as soon as somebody claims a stolen
credit card or fraud
a bunch of red flags are thrown up and
the banks get involved
and once the banks get involved it's
more than likely that the chargeback
request is going to be pushed through
and at that point there's not much
you or streamlabs for that matter can
really do about it
the other big problem with this
evidence-based approach is
as a twitch streamer what [ __ ]
evidence do you have
it's not like you're selling a physical
product that a customer can say they
never received
which is a pretty typical reason for
requesting a chargeback
you can't provide a proof of shipment
for example
because again as a streamer you're not
selling a physical product
you're selling a service that in the
case of donations
people aren't even actually buying and
that's the thing you know
first of all in paypal when there's a
refund you have to go through a twist
and you have to like explain your side
of the story
you have to explain how like i didn't
sell a product but
a service right because my service is
entertaining people
and they're they're freely donating
money the problem with paypal is that
their terms of service
are aimed towards online shops
but not towards the new digital
entertainment era
at all honestly it's pretty cool that
twitch has allowed for streaming to be a
full-time
gig for a lot of people that's a job
that didn't exist
15 years ago but the problem is is that
you have this new type of job
bumping up against an antiquated payment
system and punishing people
for doing absolutely nothing wrong when
it comes to twitch addressing this issue
they hold a very agnostic very
twitch-like stance of
hey we're just the platform this isn't
our problem
and so in the greatest irony of all
there's a ton of protection for the
people who consume
hours and hours of content but very
little protection for the people who
actually created
i was watching there's a movie called
the french connection came out in the
70s
it's a very famous um cop movie uh the
director also directed the exorcist
and it got me and there's this whole
scene where they need to tail this guy
in a car
and eventually goes wrong obviously and
that got me thinking keith is
to like if you or i had to like buddy up
and tail somebody
if we were if we'd be able to pull it
off because i think we'd be from the
word go you know like
well i'll say this devin of all the
friends i have on this earth
yeah you're one of the better ones but
i'll tell you
i would never choose to do anything like
that with you
fair enough would you like would you
choose just not to do that in general
just specifically not with me you know
like
i feel like i could tell somebody pretty
well but yeah i'm not sure
you would be the best comrade no i'm a
bit of a [ __ ]
clumsy goof so they'd probably be uh
beyond me you'd like trip into the
street
yeah yeah crash into some boxes or some
[ __ ]
but but yeah good movie go watch the
french connection it's on crave
for all you canadian people